Ngoài 20 xong năm 2018, thông tin từ bình định như chủ ước, đơn vị vừa cấp cứu thành công bế gái bà tháng tuổi biện người thân xâm hạnh.
Thế đó, nếu hai thằng xong năm 2018, bình định đã tiếp nhận được chỉ cho bế gái bà tháng tuổi nhà viện trong tình trạng trên mấu in trong vụ xin dục.
Qua tham phám và hội chần dưới nhiều tru khóa như cấp cứu, ngoại tiếp nhận, với mê, khu dức các bác sĩ xác định trẻ bị xâm hạnh tình dục.
Ngay trong đêm, bếng í đã được các bác sĩ phố thật hình cấp trong quả chính phố thật các bác sĩ phát hiện mẹ bị giác màng chính và tổ thử âm đạo khoảng 1 phy năng xe tìm mê.
Mày mắn tổ thương trường an vụng đình trực trạng. Khi mù đã tiến hành khô tạo hình lại em đạo và tưởng xin muôn cho chè.
Sau ca mù, bếng í được chuyển về khoảng 3 tiết dự đựa tục theo dõi và điều gì.
Nhờ được các thiệp kỳ tời vào trong sop tích cửa, sau hành này, tình trạng suổi của chè đã ủ định chè không xuất và đã được xuất viện.
Ngay khi phát hiện vụ việc, bán bảo vệ chè em của bình viện đã đồng hành khô trở mẹ con mẹ cải tế, tâm đi lẫn phát liếp.
Nguyên đàn ông Ké ra vụ việc đã bị bác sĩ sẽ bị sử lý nghiêm theo quy định.
Hành vi bảo lực, xong hại chè em thường đều lại hỗ quả nặng nè cả việc thích lẫn tâm liếp,
hành rộn nghiêm trọng nền xử phát triển tòa dịch của chè.
Nhưng viên kiểu cho thấy những tổng thương xóo xong hại có thể về em vụng biến ná bộ, làm xí dạm khả năng tư ri,
học tập và phát triển kiến năng só hội.
Mình viên giữ ứng kiểu gọi các gia đình, cộn đồng ý làm trước bảo lực chè em.
Hí phát hiện chè có giữ hợp bất thường, hãy đưa chẻ đi khám ngay và linh hệ tổng thài bảo vệ chè em một một một một đề nhận hỗ trở kì thời.